[Music]
okay let's go c5
let's play an excellent now let's play
nighter
because i wanted to play a knight or
last
game and again nobody seems to play the
opens to sell anymore c4
c4
okay that's not a
conventional move and it's not that bad
white aims to get some sort of a marotzi
bind structure by playing d4 on the next
move
so i don't
my memory is quite hazy on how to deal
with this properly let's start by going
knight f6
and let's try to counteract this by
developing our bishop to g4 early
the idea is that if white plays d4 now
then we can take the knight on f3 and
white will have to take with the pawn
which is kind of annoying okay now we
can play knight c6 and again d4 is
impossible because we take the knight
and then we've got two attackers
on d4 and white will have only one
defender the queen
so as long as we prevent d4 we keep this
a major hole
and we've got a nice position
now i don't think that we should play e5
here i think some people might be
tempted to do that and say well now we
really control the d4 square but when
you play e5 you create a corresponding
weakness on d5
so i think we should restrict ourselves
to e6 in order to keep d5 protected
that's an important square
we could have fianchettoed also g6
bishop g7 but i think
uh i think this is fine
yeah g6 was also was also fine i think
both moves are totally acceptable
e6 bishop e7 g6 bishop g7 okay d4 so
white loses his patience it's funny that
he waited so long and then ultimately
decides to blunder bishop takes f3 of
course was our whole point
people don't like it when they're like
only ideas are stopped
and then they panic so we're gonna be up
a pawn okay now what should we take with
this is an important moment
i i will preface this by saying
no i think there is a correct answer i
think both captures are fine
but
i think we should take with the pawn and
the reason has nothing to do with the
fact that it attacks white's knight that
the fact that it carries a threat is
less important but if you look a little
bit further i think the good thing about
pawn takes is that we can then play the
move e5 and we literally have a
protected extra passer in the center of
the board that's a huge deal now knight
takes d4 is good conceptually it's good
from the perspective of keeping control
over the d4 square but if you look very
carefully i think white has a very
annoying
resource
in response to knight takes d4 i'll let
you guys find it after the game but
let's play let's take cd
there is a specific move that i'm
worried about after an a takes d4 and
some of you already found it it is e5
yes it is e5
okay so cd
the knight has to move back then we go
e5 and once we go e5 we're up a pawn the
bishop is lame
and we are much much better close to
winning
okay e5 anyway wow
that's a bold move okay so we shouldn't
pay i mean that's a bad move that's a
bad move we can do basically whatever we
want i mean we can play d takes e5
simply and snag a second pawn but let's
try to be let's try to be clinical here
i mean we're at the level where
precision has become very very important
so
let's not uh
do anything drastic the one thing we
should not do the one thing we should
not do is we shouldn't take on e5 with a
knight because then white takes on d4
with the queen
and then you might say well wait a
second can't we take the bishop in that
position well you can but it's not worth
giving up upon
over ruining white's king side pawn
structure it's just not worth it
yeah d take c5 is clean
tight tight tight yeah d65 is clean but
i like a different move
uh i i actually like dc
i like dc
the point is after ef bishop f6 white
is not only down two pawns but lands in
even more trouble the b2 pawn is hanging
with a fork
and bc bishop takes e3 forks the two
rooks so
this is likely to lead to more
simplifications
which i like because we're up to pawns
and i just don't feel like
i just don't feel like white is
an adequate response to this
yeah that's an important point if white
plays b3 notice that we have the move c2
exposing the attack on the rook
discovered attack
no but that's a that's simple
calculation
and
i'm making an intuitive judgment call
this position just looks horrendous for
white i would call this clinical i think
it deserves it merits that label
i don't see a move for white
i just don't see a move for white
i think okay rook b1 that is the best i
think that's probably the only move
actually oh yeah that is a very good
move um
i would go so far as to say that i
missed that move
and had i seen it it probably would have
changed my mind on what we should have
played
that's annoying because that that
basically forces it forces us to
liquidate we'll take our two extra pawns
no no problem but
that's quite a bummer i just i forgot
about rook b1
now we should take here we should
simplify
and we can primo bishop b2 whatever
scrap the video next next video yeah
no it totally escaped me though for some
reason i thought that white has to
defend the pawn of the queen
and then we had tactics with knight e4
which i'll show after the game
so
mistake mistake there
should have played d we'll check with
the engine but i'm okay what is this i
mean our opponent's not recapturing any
pawns
okay so so
we need to prioritize here what is our
top priority in this position is it what
is the priority and our priority
dictates what move we should play
so knight d4 is interesting but it does
give up b7 to castle our priority is to
castle right if we castle
then everything is safe we're up a bunch
of pawns
so i think a lot of people here would
react instinctively
to
the d6 pawn being hanging and you would
say well let's play e5 or let's play
knight t4 but all of that is very
complicated the simplest is just a
castle king side yeah we give up d6 with
tempo big deal
bfd we just go rookie eight
okay c5
this is nothing we can circumvent this
this is not a problem
um at least we've castled now and we
don't have to worry about our king and
we can focus on
converting our two extra pawns
okay
so
while this is not a problem the pieces
i've highlighted
they are annoying so ideally we would
like to successfully deal with the dark
squared bishop and we would like to deal
with it
without giving up our b2 pawn so we
should keep our bishop on f6 now you
might say okay how do we deal with the
bishop on d6 well why is the bishop on
e6 annoying well it's annoying because
there's a pawn on c5 right that's
supporting that bishop that's where the
source of annoyance comes from so you
might say well i want to play b6 but you
can't play b6 because the knight on c6
is hanging
so then you might say okay what if we
defend the knight on c6 first and that's
where i come up with the move rook c8
we want to play b6 and undermine the
support of this bishop once the bishop
loses its support
it becomes a sitting duck
yeah quinn a5 was tempting but i will
show why i didn't like it afterwards
hopefully the logic was clear
bishop b4
bishop before what does our opponent
want
probably want some sort of
shenanigans with queen h5 but queen h5
is not a problem
i think i'm pretty sure we can uh
proceed with our plan
yeah i don't i don't see
so the one thing you would have to be
careful of b6 does loosen the knight
right it loosens it
um so you would have to check for
various forks
and double attacks and stuff like that
um you know white is a move like queen
a4 here
which could potentially be annoying we
could move our queen up to d7 if
necessary to reinforce the knight again
but you would want to be careful about
that you know
queen a4 played
okay so it's important to point out that
bc
is wrong
why is it wrong it's wrong because the
bishop takes c6
and if you take the bishop on d6 the
rook on e8 is hanging
so in fact i think queen d7 is quite
important supporting the knight on c6
and finally we are ready to remove
remove the pawn on c5 and once it's
removed i can guarantee you that white's
position is going to collapse like a
house of cards because white's only
asset in this position
is that bishop on d6
all right get out of here
we are not afraid of any discoveries
there is nothing
right there's no
yeah bishop takes
okay now where should we put our queen
and i have to give our opponent a lot of
credit he's defending as as well as he
could be
well i don't like queen b7 right why
walk into a pin you want to eliminate
potential sources of
trouble
and queen b7 potentially walks into a
move like rook d6
and i actually think that might win the
night so
queen c7 is very important here
yeah it's actually the only move
now my guess is that he might return to
d6 but then we can sort of circle around
we can circle back to d to b6
yeah gen saki would make that move
i think we're safe
yep there we go
okay queen v6 we are in good shape
notice that all throughout this entire
operation we have
kept
we've kept the bishop on f6 in order to
support the pawn on b2 this is
you know we need to support this pawn
with everything that we've got it's like
the golden fleece it's the
pride of our position we cannot give
this pawn up
yeah white is starting to shoot blanks
that's right
you can sense that white's uh initiative
is fizzling out and
once it's our turn
it you know the wind is going to come
very very quickly
so
what we do next depends quite heavily on
what white does rook d3
okay does this create a threat i don't
think so
we're never really worried about these
kinds of moves because we can always
play g6
okay so what should we do this is an
instructive moment
because i think a lot of people here
would just sort of get lost
and not realize you know like what what
specifically
should we do thank you nanime for the
raid we have a very very strong move
here we have a very very strong move now
what do i notice in this position okay
i notice a couple of things the moment
that rook d3 is played the first thing
that i notice is that it weakens the
back rank
and if we can get a rook to c1 well that
wouldn't be checkmate because the rook
could come back to d1 but that would be
a big deal
now what do we need in order to get the
rook to c1 we probably need to move the
knight so you start thinking okay well
where can i put the knight and hopefully
you also notice that the queen is
x-raying the bishop what is the bishop
defended by well why did we why did we
play b6 we played it in order to make
the bishop more vulnerable so let's make
a move that exploits the vulnerability
of that bishop but it's not knight e5
95 is a one move threat that doesn't do
all that much if the rook just moves
back
that's not how you attack the bishop you
attack the bishop by intercepting the
rook and the bishop you play knight t4
and this simultaneously creates several
threats first of all you're attacking
the bishop second of all rook c1 is very
annoying although we should be very
careful about making that move because
now white's queen is making contact with
that rook something we should notice but
there is a third threat here which is
the reason i played this move
does anybody see it
this is virtually unstoppable i think
like it has a very strong move here
actually to stop it but it's it's almost
unstoppable does anybody see the third
threat we have
look carefully 92 check and knight back
to c3 forking
the queen and the rook on b1 that is the
third threat 92 knight c3
how do i how do i see this well any time
queen and the rook are in portable
positions i mean this is just this is
just tactical pattern recognition
there's no science to this that the
science is just pattern recognition
you just need to see the fork i mean
it's the kind of thing you either see or
you don't
okay
so
white is lost
yeah mr white yes science
if the d3 rook takes yeah but we don't
need to move the stroke at all the point
is that we will take the rook on d4
oh oh oh oh you're asking if the rook
takes here well no our bishop will take
yeah yeah that's a great question what
he was saying is that
it's very important again that the
bishop also controls c3
because otherwise indeed the rook would
have taken
so
the one thing that you can notice and
and white resides one thing that you can
notice is that the margins of our wins
are a little bit more narrow like i'm
relying more heavily on specific
calculation where if one line doesn't
work it's actually a problem whereas in
earlier games like
you know there are like 15 different
wins in most positions
good game so let's go over it
so c4 has been played against me once
it's not a bad move i mean it's it's a
move
you know it's it's a third rate it's a
third rate sideline
um
the purpose the why is c4 even played
well if you play
i mean if you play as one would a knight
or right if you play a move a6 for
example when white's gonna play d4
and get kind of a favorable marotzi bind
structure this by the way is the reason
why
it is considered inaccurate
to play a6 here first right this is why
in the night or black starts with knight
f6 and then plays a6 this was taught to
me a very long time ago a6 allows the
extra option of c4
which controls the center more tightly
now
if you've allowed this the best that
black can do in a situation like this is
to to set up what's called a hedgehog
hedgehog setup i'm sure that most people
in the chat
probably you've if you've been in chess
long enough you've heard of that term
now the hedgehog setup refers to a very
specific arrangement of pieces
that is frequently played against kind
of a marotzi setup
and it is characterized by the following
arrangement of minor pieces you play e6
um the order doesn't matter right now
i'm like just showing you the moves you
play queen c7 b6
bishop b7 and knight bd7 this is the
hedgehog structure
so it's characterized by a sort of
cheveningen pawn formation
and then four of these pieces on the uh
on the the seventh rank the queen the
bishop the knight and the other bishop
so this is what characterizes the
hedgehog the pawns and the pieces
now
sergey shipov noted russian commentator
and jim has written like a 500 page book
on the hedgehog it's an incredibly
complicated structure it first started
to get popular around the 70s my former
coach
left sakis
um
popularized the hedgehog in like the
late 70s early 80s
and
the interesting thing about the hedgehog
is that it can be played against a lot
of different structures white can set up
his pieces
uh his or her pieces in in many
different ways
so
the hedgehog is more of a setup than it
is an actual one it's not actually one
line
but it can lead to some beautiful wins
and and incredible ideas for black
one game that i remember in the hedgehog
that could give you a pretty good
impression of like the way that it's
played
hopefully this is interesting i mean
this is a bit of a detour into a line
that most people won't play but
i i think
just general chess education is
important
just educating yourself on things that
are out there
is important because
you can always borrow ideas and
you know just being knowledgeable i
think in in across different openings
that you don't play is it's just good in
general
you know it's just just being educated
in in a chess context
yeah there have been some famous
kasparov car karpov games in the
hedgehog but one slightly less famous
game that i
really really like is this one
uh kaspar uh sorry taimanav against
yusuf two soviet gm's
so you can see 1982 at this point the
hedgehog is becoming like pretty damn
popular
so you can see here
yep they get this structure
so there's e6 a6 knight bishop queen
okay black delays queen c7 and then
plays it
okay so
here black applies a super popular
hedgehog idea you play queen b8
bishop d8 and bishop c7
super super typical hedgehog idea you
defend b6 and then you aim at the h2
pawn
which can become important if black
breaks through with d5 later and then
the hedgehog like black has these two
pawn breaks b5 and d5 that white needs
to be very very careful and vigilant
about watching
so
in this position yusupov
uh
applies an idea and i remember reading
yusuf buff's commentary to this game
and what's amazing about the idea that
yusuf carries out on this position is
that he learned it directly from robert
fisher
fisher
had a game
um
fisher had a game against wolf anderson
in uh
an olympiad 10 years before
the current one was played
in which fisher applies this incredible
idea it's generally considered that
fisher was the first
to apply this idea
um just a second
so i'll show you the full
order of operations here
fisher plays this crazy idea in the 70s
and then yusuf applies it in his own
game
so here's the fischer game
here's the fischer game
yeah it's a fisher from 1970. uh fischer
plays the reverse hedgehog so he plays
the hedgehog structure but he plays it
with the white pieces
and
you can see the hedgehog and here fisher
does something crazy he goes king h1
then he goes rook g1 anderson is like
la dee da improving my pieces and then
knight e4 and then g4
he starts pushing this king's side pawn
then he doubles on the g file and he
just checkmates him
just checkmates him
knight h4
and then knight f5 look at this knight
f5 bang
if you take it then gfgf
bishop f5 rook g7 oh let me give up the
queen for two pieces no knight f6 first
then i take your queen and then the
other rook
just incredible power
then the other knight gets to c5 so he
just destroyed i mean just destroys him
and fischer ends up winning you can look
at this game in its entirety on your own
but back we go to the taimanov game
what did yusupopov do
in this position who can tell me
who can tell me what yusupov
played in this position
yeah ulf anderson was very young it was
sub 20 i think yeah he plays king h8 and
he plays rook g8
then he plays g5
and then he plays rook g6 he literally
applies the idea move for move
and then he plays beautifully he gets
the queen
around the king's side pushes g4 bang
bang
and then he gets the bishop around to h4
the attack rages on and then he wins
upon takes here
takes here and then takes white's
central pawn out of the picture and he
ends up winning the game this is part of
the yeah i started youtube video
um
so just a beautiful win
so
that's enough but to go back to
um what i'm saying to conclude
so
a6 here would not have been a mistake
but it would have allowed white to get
into the hedgehog pawn structure
yeah the engine the engine is okay with
a hedgehog it's not refuted or anything
okay
so bishop g4
again the point of this move is aimed
against d4
you know we want to take on f3 here and
we want to force white to play gf which
is
quite undesirable then we go knight c6
and we're in pretty good shape
okay does that make sense so bishop b2
knight c6 castle's e6
i think black is already slightly better
i think i think white probably should
have played d4
because at this point this gaping hole
on d4 is no good for white okay rookie
one is weird
yeah and then d4 blunders upon the way
white should play this is play d white
should play d3
d3 bishop e3 maybe prepare d4
yeah white should prepare d4
um
and the game you know probably still
closer to equality than to anything else
the d4 we take it
okay so why didn't i play knight takes
d4 the reason is because of this move e5
which i found to be quite annoying
because we've exposed our back side the
bottom b7 is exposed
so if we take on e5 then white can take
b7
and i thought this was a little bit
unconvincing
but if we take on f3 then white takes on
f3 and then again takes on v7
and again i
black is better but i wasn't too
convinced by this
um i'm quite positive the cd is just
better
okay so e5
uh e5 e5 is is obviously panic very bad
and here i made a mistake definitely dc
dc is misjudgment
the best move was was just d e
and this this pawn mass is just
going to destroy white
okay knight e4 maybe keep some chances
alive if white plays knight back to e2
then we have e4
yeah 94 i thought this wasn't like
totally super convincing because this
bishop is annoying and bl white is
threatening to take on c6 and take on e5
so i just wasn't like 100
sold on this
um
and so for this reason i took here and
then took back
um
okay
if bishop takes knight
a bishop takes knight we take it what's
the what's the issue here
because the knight is still hanging so
you can't take on e5
right
okay
so anyways we took on c3 we took back on
f6 and i just forgot about rook b1
somebody asked in the chat why rook b1
is so strong it's less that it's like
strong per se just defends against the
threat of cb and the other the
additional problem
is that if we just sort of
nonchalantly simplify then after rook
takes me to the rook is perfectly
positioned to attack black's only
weakness b7
and i found this to be
very unconvincing white actually gets
quite the initiative here
okay maybe queen c7 and black is just
okay but
i didn't want to allow this
so that's why we went
oh no i did i did want to allow this i
played cb sorry sorry i said this is the
line i was going to go for
but i was worried about this position
although i think black and castle in the
next move i actually think we're fine
so like this exists
but but here at the end we just go rook
c8 and i think we're fine
i think we're fine
um i don't see a clear move for white if
like queen b1
and then we go rogue b8
and we defend b7 that's fine
um
did we have to take v2 in the first
place asks bonsai grow no well no
no but what do you propose instead i
mean if we had castled instead
uh the good thing about cb is that it
forces white to give up the bishop pair
here i was worried about bc
here i was worried about bc because the
pawn on b7 hangs and if we take on c3
and say yeah but the rokans but the rook
can move up to e3 and attack the bishop
again
um so so it's not so simple
bishop d4 with d3
and then the bishop hangs and then if
you move the bishop back to the pawn
hangs
and white's bishops are good
and if you go bishop c5 then the other
pawn hangs so whichever way you slice it
you're going to lose a pawn here so
that's why i played cb okay bishop f4 is
pretty pretty wild
and here we decided to castle
um
was casey for it to threaten a fork
option
what do you mean by kc4
where and
i don't understand where where you're
talking about it
sorry
was night before
oh here yeah yeah so night before you
can give a check on a4 and force the
knight back and that's a disaster
because then white can take
any time your king is uncastled remember
you have to look at this four
okay so cb bishop f4 castles
so we sacrificed one of our pawns back
but we've castled
and after c5 i think an instructive
moment
where we just basically decided on what
the top priority was and then
came up with an idea to carry out our
plan right so
we start by saying the bishop is white's
strongest piece we want to
get rid of it but it's not easy to get
rid of it because bishop b7 would
blunder the pawn on b2 a lot of you
wanted to go queen a5
but after queen b3 i wasn't exactly sure
how black should proceed
this is the move
that i feared quite a bit
the problem is that the b7 pawn hangs
and uh
yeah i'll get to e5 in a second but
you you can't play rook b that really
hurts you the fact that we can't play
rook b8 really hurts us so i wasn't sure
exactly what we would do here uh 94 we
go queen b7
and and white as a passer like why why
are we allowing all of this right so i
just thought it was simpler and and more
safe to go rook c8
okay so e5 why why would you go e5 i
mean e5 doesn't accomplish anything it
also weakens as you as you're saying the
light squares and not to mention that it
it cuts off the connection between the
bishop and the pawn
okay um
then knight c2 and knight a3
well let's analyze so here here you want
here here here
yeah maybe because knight a3 is coming
next
yeah it's possible that this was good
yep yeah maybe maybe this this is good
for black but
i don't know i was i i was too lazy to
calculate i guess uh
so now we go b6 we undermine the bishop
oh sorry sorry keep doing that
queen a4 attacking the knight queen d7
defending the knight
getting rid of the pawn sliding the
queen over to c7
the queen circles around to v6 and now
we intercept the bishop with knight d4
bang bang bang
easy
very very easy
yeah short game but a lot of a lot of
interesting moments so hopefully you
enjoyed
uh
yeah so bishop b4 i thought would
prolong the game i mean white resigned
but
bishop b4 would have kept white in the
game
so here i was intending to play rook e
to d8
uh the point is to get the rook away
from the queen's
contact with it and after rook takes p2
you have the move rook c1 check
rook d1 and now knight e2 check it's
simple simple tactics
and then the rook is toast and black
white is mated
yeah a lot of a lot of
meat there to unpack
[Music]